Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field, the principles can work for you.
大家好，我是玛丽安。在深入今天的节目之前，我想快速通知大家一个正在进行的令人兴奋的消息。如果你曾好奇如何创造源源不断的被动收入，而不是没完没了地用时间换取金钱，那你一定会喜欢丽莎·约翰逊（我的商业导师）发起的“争夺经常性收入挑战”。这个挑战旨在帮你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是立志成为心理学家、心理健康从业者，还是身处完全不同的领域，这些原则都对你适用。
There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide. episode. With Dr. Marianne Trent Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. I, as ever, am Dr. Marianne Trent.
丽莎本人还会提供丰厚的奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，将有机会赢得与我（玛丽安·特伦特博士）一对一的教练咨询。你想了解更多吗？你当然想。前往我的 Linktree（Dr. Marianne Trent），查看我的社交媒体频道，或者给我发个私信，我会把所有细节告诉你。好了，让我们继续今天的节目。如果你正寻找成为心理学家的方法，那就让它成为你的指南。欢迎收听《有志心理学家播客》，我是你们的老朋友玛丽安·特伦特博士。
Let's think today about opportunities for you to do teaching as an aspiring psychologist. Of course, it can be one of the really useful core competencies to demonstrate your readiness for becoming either a trainee clinical psychologist or other types of psychologist too. It's really helpful if you're able to demonstrate that you've had experience of teaching information to others. It might look like actual teaching, perhaps you've done English as a foreign language stuff maybe you've had time in Japan or something teaching English maybe you've done Camp America type stuff and done mentoring and sort of leadership and nurturing and child care or maybe actually you're
今天我们来谈谈作为有志心理学家可以参与教学的机会。当然，这是展示你准备好成为临床心理学实习生或其他类型心理学家的一项非常核心且有用的胜任能力。如果你能证明自己拥有向他人传授信息的经验，那将非常有帮助。这可能看起来像实际的教学，也许你做过英语作为外语教学的相关工作，比如在日本或其他地方教过英语；也许你做过类似美国夏令营的工作，进行过辅导、领导、培养和儿童照料；或者其实你正在
retraining and you have been a teacher teacher before it might be like me my teaching experience when I got onto clinical training had been from doing training within the private hospital that I worked in. I was in a forensic service and I mentioned in a previous podcast episode that one of my responsibilities was doing behavioural observations for a specific tool, which we called the Mod overt aggression scale. It was a little fiddly and the idea was that actually in order for it to be valid and for the data to count that everyone really needed to be using the tool in the same way. We were needing to make sure that they were interpreting it in the same way so the levels of aggression or violence or anger and I seem to recall that if someone had been really really angry you know kind of ended up breaking someone's leg for example which would obviously be extreme um you know the most extreme sort of score that you could
重新培训，以前就是一名老师。就像我一样，当我进入临床培训时，我的教学经验来自于我在其中工作的私立医院内部培训。我曾在法医服务部门工作过，我在之前的播客节目中提到过，我的职责之一是为特定工具进行行为观察，我们称之为“莫德显性攻击量表”。这个工具有点繁琐，其目的是为了确保数据有效且计分准确，每个人实际上都需要以相同的方式使用该工具。我们需要确保他们对其进行相同的解读，包括攻击、暴力或愤怒的程度。我记得如果有人真的非常非常生气，你知道的，比如最后打断了别人的腿，这显然是极端的……你知道的，这是你能得到的
get um that you want them to obviously report it in a certain way but if someone for example had kicked a chair then that would be less extreme. So we needed to make sure that people were recording consistently, if that makes sense. Because it was a bit fiddly, it was important that we were communicating to the unit staff how we needed that to be done. We would do that at the induction, which happened when people joined the hospital. But also, if you work for a private hospital or you work for any large organization you will likely be oh so familiar
最高级别的分数，你希望他们以某种特定方式报告；但如果有人踢了一把椅子，那程度就没那么极端。所以我们需要确保人们的记录保持一致，如果这说得通的话。因为这个过程有点繁琐，向单位员工传授我们所需要的方式就显得尤为重要。我们会在新员工加入医院时的入职培训中进行讲解。此外，如果你在私立医院或任何大型机构工作，你很可能对
with refresher yearly training. We decided that actually it wasn't great use of the qualified psychologist's time to be doing all this training because actually it was predictable absolutely the psychologist had a hand in designing the training and supporting us with that we decided that actually yes our time would be well placed and it would be good for our experience and for our developing relationships with people in the hospital in our units to do that training ourselves It was in a training venue in the hospital and it was quite a formal situation to sort of 20-30 people at a time but it gave me and my colleague the opportunity to be able to tick teaching off on our competencies for the big form. It might be useful for you to think about whether anything that you're doing in your day-to-day job that you
每年一次的复训非常熟悉。我们当时决定，让合格的心理学家去做所有这些培训其实并不是对他们时间的最佳利用，因为虽然培训内容完全是可以预见的，心理学家也确实参与了培训的设计并为我们提供了支持，但我们决定，由我们自己来进行培训，不仅能让我们的时间得到很好的利用，也有利于积累经验，并促进我们在医院和科室中与同事的关系。培训是在医院的一个培训场地进行的，气氛相当正式，一次大约有20到30人，但这给我和我的同事提供了一个机会，让我们能够在重大申请表格的胜任能力项中勾选教学经验。思考你在日常工作中是否有什么事情可以
could help upskill others on either as a repeatable predictable thing or maybe you could do some sort of consultation or some sort of formulation session for people regularly or actually you know teaching them some skills in some nice maybe some nice soothing breathing that then they might be able to teach their clients could you maybe pick some strategies that you currently use and help teach them to the staff that you work with or maybe you've got the opportunity to run a group when I was in my assistance role I ran a group for old adults who had dementia diagnosis and we implemented the cognitive stimulation therapy group which was fully lovely but there's teaching elements in that as well of course. Groups are of course a great experience for you as an aspiring psychologist and great experience for you as a qualified
帮助他人提升技能，无论是重复性的、可预测的事情，还是你可以定期为人们做一些咨询或构思（formulation）会议，或者实际上，你知道的，教给他们一些很好的放松呼吸技巧，然后他们可以把这些教给他们的来访者。你能挑选一些你目前使用的策略，并教给你一起工作的员工吗？或者你可能有机会运营一个小组。当我担任助理时，我为诊断为痴呆症的老年人开办了一个小组，我们实施了认知刺激疗法小组，这非常棒，但其中当然也有教学元素。对有志心理学家来说，小组活动无疑是极好的经验，对合格的
psychologist too. It's just useful thinking about actually if there's a protocol or a manual or some book or approach that you really like and you think would really resonate with your clients then it can be worth thinking through in your supervision about whether that's something you could use and to bring to the service and to teach others about. So don't be afraid to ask and to think outside the box and to think actually about the benefits of what you are offering to your service, but you are allowed to benefit too. Actually, I think the pandemic certainly caused the NHS to modernise by about 20 years within the space of about a year. It meant that we were able to bring online more flexible ways of working, which meant that I was able to bring online more flexible ways of working which meant that I was
心理学家来说也是如此。思考一下，如果有一个你真的很喜欢并认为会与你的来访者产生共鸣的协议、手册、书籍或方法，那么在督导中讨论这是否是你可以使用、引入服务并教给其他人的东西，是非常有价值的。所以，不要害怕去询问，去打破常规，去思考你为服务带来的价值，同时你也有权从中受益。事实上，大流行无疑在一年之内促使英国国民保健制度（NHS）现代化了大约20年。这意味着我们能够上线更多样、更灵活的工作方式，这意味着我能够上线更灵活的工作方式，这意味着我能够
able to host zoom groups and actually had I stayed in the NHS it was my plan to create a waiting list group where people could come along monthly and do stabilization work with me there was no need to book and anyone who was either male or female on the separate list depending on which week it was who was on the waiting list for psychology would be able to come along via zoom at this set time on a set date and come along if they were free and if they wanted to do stabilization work as a standalone session and I would have been really super excited to do that so maybe if that's something you think your service could benefit from then you could run that with a qualified psychologist.
主持 Zoom 小组。事实上，如果我留在 NHS，我的计划是创建一个候补名单小组，人们可以每月来一次，和我一起做稳定化（stabilization）工作。这不需要预约，无论是在候补名单上男宾还是女宾（取决于哪一周），只要有空且想把稳定化工作作为独立课程来做，就可以在设定的日期通过 Zoom 准时参加。我会为此感到非常兴奋，所以如果你的服务也能从中受益，你或许可以和一位合格的心理学家一起运营它。
Or if you actually feel like you have the skills and experience to be able to do that yourself with the assistance of a more junior member, perhaps, or someone else too in your team. Because it's useful to run groups in twos just to help with things you might miss, especially when it's via Zoom, because you can't have eyes everywhere. But could that be an opportunity for you to do some teaching and so you know some sort of group work so there's absolutely a crossover between teaching training and group work because you need to make sure that your style is such that people can engage with what you're saying stick around and I will be right back after this quick advert. qualified. So come and take a look. It's right here in this book. It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective. It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective. Hi, my name is Beth and I'm a psychological wellbeing practitioner from Newcastle.
或者，如果你觉得自己在团队中更有资深成员或其他人的协助下，有能力和经验自己完成这项工作。因为小组活动最好由两人一组来运营，以避免遗漏某些事情，特别是通过 Zoom 进行时，因为你无法面面俱到。但这是否能成为你进行教学和某种小组工作的机会呢？教学、培训和小组工作之间绝对有交叉点，因为你需要确保你的风格能够吸引人们参与你所说的话。留下来，这段简短的广告后我马上回来。获取资格。快来看看吧。就在这本书里。《临床心理学家集体》。《临床心理学家集体》。你好，我叫贝丝，是来自纽卡斯尔的一名心理健康从业者。
I just wanted to say the biggest thank you to the contributors of the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I've enjoyed reading this so much and I've loved having an insight into the range of backgrounds and experiences people have prior to applying for the doctorate and it's been really interesting seeing the potential barriers to the application as well and how I can try and work around this. I really started to doubt myself and whether I was good enough to apply for the Clinical Psychology Doctorate but this has really given me the confidence boost that I needed to give it a shot so the biggest thank you ever This is the old guide filled with lessons and experience that will help you get qualified. So come and take a look.
我只想对《临床心理学家集体》一书的撰稿人表达由衷的感谢。我非常享受阅读这本书，也很高兴能深入了解人们在申请博士学位之前拥有的各种背景和经验。同时，看到申请过程中潜在的障碍以及我如何绕过这些障碍，也非常有趣。我曾经开始怀疑自己，怀疑自己是否足够优秀去申请临床心理学博士，但这确实给了我迈出这一步所需的信心。真的非常感谢！这是一本充满经验和教训的老指南，能帮助你获得资格。快来看看吧。
It's right here in this book. It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective. It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective Is it just me who ends up singing those jingles in the shower when I'm chopping food? I just love them. So it can be useful to think about the ways that you can tap into teaching too. When I was on the doctorate sometimes we had people who were like local assistant psychologists coming along to some of our teaching sessions and I recall that happening at least on a couple of occasions. So it might be worth you making contact with your
就在这本书里。《临床心理学家集体》。《临床心理学家集体》。难道只有我一个人在洗澡或切菜时会不由自主地哼唱这些广告歌吗？我太喜欢它们了。因此，思考如何涉足教学也会很有用。当我读博士时，有时会有当地的助理心理学家来参加我们的一些教学课程，我记得这种情况至少发生过好几次。所以，你或许可以联系
local course and asking if any of the teaching sessions are kind of more open forum because that certainly was the case when I was there. It was the specialist teaching modules in the third year and if they were under subscribed and where I was there was like two different universities that you could opt into the Friday teaching in year three but it meant that sometimes there was like two different universities that you could opt into the Friday teaching in year three but it meant that sometimes there was just you know a few people on the course on that day and they might have loads of empty spaces it makes sense for people to benefit from those so it might be that there's a similar option for you in your local area and then you can get your experience really up to date really useful teaching and see how it's done and
当地的课程负责人，询问是否有任何教学课程是开放式的，因为当我还在那里时确实如此。那是第三年的专业教学模块，如果报名人数不足——我所在的学校有两所不同的大学可以选择参加三年级的周五教学——这意味着有时课程当天只有
think about whether you might be able to do some teaching, some training or some consultation. So I hope you found that useful. Just don't be afraid to think outside the box. If you think this might be useful for you to thicken up this particular competency, then could you, you know, decide to take this on? Maybe you could think about, you know, reading a particular book, maybe that your whole department might not have time to read, and then like do a little digest for them, or a research paper, or go along to some training event on behalf of your department and then teach it to them. Disseminate the pertinent points in a much shorter period of time. And you could get a bit, you know, whizzy here on your PowerPoint or your Canva, whatever floats your boat.
寥寥数人，会有大量空位。让大家充分利用这些资源是合理的，所以在你当地可能也有类似的选项，这样你就可以获得最新的经验、真正有用的教学，并看看它是如何完成的，然后
But could you demonstrate that you have the ability to teach, to, you know, to do what we call comprehension and so to comprehend what's been said and put it across then to others in a way that helps them in a meaningful way. I think this flexibility and this thinking outside the box-ness is one of the things that we're particularly good at in the psychology field and for you really to start building and thickening those competencies for your own career as an aspiring psychologist. And it might well just be the type of thing that you can use, if only to develop your own confidence, before then going on to do something a little bit more formal in terms of teaching. And if you've done your psychology undergrad thesis, perhaps you could present that to your department, if there's any useful learning points there for them too. It's about thinking about creating those opportunities. Why did I
思考你是否也能进行一些教学、培训或咨询。希望这对你有所帮助。不要害怕跳出常规思考。如果你认为这有助于加强这一特定的胜任能力，那么你是否可以决定承担起来？也许你可以考虑阅读一本你的整个部门可能没有时间阅读的特定书籍，然后为他们做一个简短的摘要，或者阅读一篇研究报告，或者代表你的部门去参加某个培训活动，然后再教给他们。在更短的时间内传播要点。你可以在你的 PowerPoint 或 Canva 上发挥创意，怎么高兴怎么来。但是，你能证明自己有能力教学，也就是我们所说的理解力——能够理解所表达的内容，然后以一种有意义的方式传授给他人，从而帮助到他们吗？我认为这种灵活性和跳出常规的思维方式，正是我们在心理学领域特别擅长的能力之一，这能为你作为有志心理学家真正开始构建和加强你的职业胜任能力打下基础。这可能正是那种能够培养你自信心的类型，在此之后，你再去从事一些更正式的教学工作。如果你做过心理学本科毕业论文，也许你可以向你的部门展示它，如果其中有对他们有用的学习点的话。这都是关于如何创造这些机会的。为什么我刚刚
just say creating so weirdly? Sorry about that one. If actually you recognise that there's a lot of skills and talents in your department, then could you maybe put together a monthly programme where you all teach each other? You could perhaps be the lead. You could hold it together, head it up. And you might maybe do more spaces in the year than other people because it's your baby. And yeah, I hope you have some fun with this and that you find it helpful. If you've got any other ideas for how you can cram some teaching training and consultation into your work then do give me a shout and I'd really be happy to expand on this further I hope you find it useful and if you do
把“创造”这个词说得那么奇怪？真是不好意思。如果你确实认识到你们部门有很多技能和天赋，那么你是否可以组织一个每月的项目，让大家互相教学？也许你可以成为负责人。你可以把大家凝聚在一起，担任领头人。由于这是你的心血结晶，你可能会比其他人承担更多的场次。是的，希望你能从中获得乐趣并觉得有帮助。如果你对如何在工作中塞进一些教学、培训和咨询有任何其他想法，请告诉我，我非常乐意对此做进一步的展开。希望你觉得有用，如果确实如此
please leave me a review rate it and of course subscribe take care and I'll catch up with you very soon if you're looking to become a psychologist then let this be your guide. With this podcast, you'll be on your way to being qualified. It's the Aspiring Psychologist podcast with Dr. Marianne My name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist it just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me of confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself so if you're
请给我写个好评、打个分，当然还要订阅。保重，我们很快再聊。如果你正在寻找成为心理学家的方法，那就让它成为你的指南。通过这个播客，你将迈向获得资格的道路。这是由玛丽安博士主持的《有志心理学家播客》。我叫亚娜，是一名心理健康实习规培生。我读了《临床心理学家集体》这本书。我觉得所有不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的经历都非常有趣，通往那里的途径竟然有这么多，这让我感到惊讶，而且并没有成为其中一员的完美途径，这让我充满信心，告诉自己我并没有做错，并减少了自己的压力。所以，如果你对
feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist, I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay. But trust me, you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
成为临床心理学感到有些不安，我绝对推荐这本书，它能让你安心，一切都会好起来的。但相信我，一旦你开始读，你就不会把书放下了。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。